En este video vamos a hablar acerca del
equilibrio mecánico. Imagina una lámpara
que cuelga del techo, quizá algo parecido a esto.
¿Cuáles son las fuerzas que están actuando sobre
ella? Pausa el video y piensa un poco en ello. La
lámpara cuelga y está en reposo, las fuerzas que
actúan sobre ella son la gravedad y la tensión del
cable que conecta a la lámpara al techo e impide
que caiga al suelo. Son fuerzas que actúan sólo
en el sentido vertical, como puedes observar. El
equilibrio mecánico ocurre cuando la suma de todas
las fuerzas externas que actúan sobre un cuerpo es
igual a cero. Otra forma de decir esto es que: un
cuerpo se encuentra en equilibrio de traslación
cuando la fuerza resultante de la suma de todas
las fuerzas externas que actúan sobre él es nula.
La suma de F es igual a cero. Esta es la primera
condición de equilibrio: el cuerpo no tiene
aceleración alguna, se mantiene en reposo o en un
movimiento rectilíneo uniforme. Debemos recordar
que hay que considerar las fuerzas que actúan
sobre el cuerpo en todas las direcciones, en
todos los ejes coordinados: el eje X, el eje Y y
el eje Z. Esto lo podemos expresar de dos formas:
la matemática, que sería algo así como: la suma
de todas las fuerzas externas que actúan sobre el
cuerpo debe ser igual a cero, y también se puede
expresar de forma geométrica, haciendo un diagrama
con todas las fuerzas externas involucradas,
como este ejemplo de fuerzas coplanares:
en el caso del equilibrio mecánico forman un
polígono cerrado. Para comprender e identificar
cuáles son las fuerzas externas que actúan sobre
un cuerpo se recomienda usar la forma geométrica,
hacer un diagrama de cuerpo libre, también
conocido como diagrama de fuerzas sobre un
cuerpo libre. El diagrama debe tener el cuerpo
a analizar en el centro y también todas las
fuerzas externas que actúan sobre él, en forma de
vectores, y las etiquetas adecuadas. Recuerda que
las flechas indican la dirección y la magnitud de
las fuerzas, y de preferencia los vectores deben
dibujarse en el punto de aplicación de la fuerza.
Por ejemplo, en el caso de nuestra lámpara,
la dibujamos en el centro y, como ya habíamos
visto, las únicas fuerzas que actúan sobre ella
son verticales, la aceleración de la gravedad
que jala su masa hacia el centro de la Tierra
y la tensión del cable que sostiene la lámpara, la
sujeta del techo en dirección hacia arriba y evita
que se caiga. En este ejemplo todas las fuerzas
están en el eje Y, no hay fuerzas en el eje X ni
en el eje Z. Podríamos decir que la lámpara que
vimos al principio es pesada, digamos que tiene
una masa de 10 kilogramos; la aceleración que la
gravedad terrestre ejerce sobre la lámpara es de
10 kg (9.8 m/s²), o sea 98 N. Estamos usando un
valor aproximado para la gravedad terrestre. Por
convención decimos que la dirección hacia abajo
es negativa, por lo que el vector de la fuerza
de gravedad es -98 N, y como la lámpara está en
reposo quiere decir que la fuerza de tensión es
igual en magnitud a la fuerza de gravedad pero en
dirección opuesta, así que el resultado de la suma
de las fuerzas es cero. Otro ejemplo, un poco más
interesante, sería el de un cuerpo en movimiento
a velocidad constante. Imagina a una patinadora
sobre hielo que se mueve a velocidad constante.
En este caso no hay aceleración. Digamos que
la patinadora tiene una masa de 50 kg. Primero
hacemos el diagrama de cuerpo libre, dibujando
todas las fuerzas externas que actúan sobre la
patinadora. En el diagrama representamos a la
patinadora como un punto que corresponde a su
centro de masa. En el diagrama está la fuerza
de gravedad apuntando hacia abajo, la fuerza
normal que siente la patinadora debido a que está
sobre la pista de hielo y apunta hacia arriba y,
como la patinadora se está deslizando a velocidad
constante sin que una fuerza externa horizontal
intervenga, no hay fuerzas externas en sentido
horizontal. La fuerza de gravedad es la masa de
la patinadora multiplicada por la aceleración
gravitacional terrestre: 50 kg (9.8 m/s²),
de nuevo un valor aproximado para la gravedad
terrestre, y es igual a 490 N, y como apunta
hacia abajo la escribimos con un signo negativo.
La fuerza normal apunta en dirección opuesta a la
fuerza de gravedad, hacia arriba, y tiene la misma
magnitud pero en sentido contrario, por lo que es
igual a 490 N. Un cuerpo con movimiento uniforme
mantiene siempre su velocidad y, por tanto, no
tiene perturbaciones externas, por lo que se puede
decir que está en equilibrio. Siempre y cuando no
intervenga una fuerza externa adicional, el objeto
puede mantenerse indefinidamente moviéndose con
velocidad constante. Y con esto espero te haya
quedado más claro qué es el equilibrio mecánico,
así como el uso del diagrama de cuerpo
libre para identificar las fuerzas que
actúan sobre un cuerpo, y así determinar si
ese cuerpo está en equilibrio mecánico o no.